- Why do you curse so much?
(dramatic music)
- Fuck, fuck, fuck--
- Fuck, fuck, fuck.
♪ Mother, motherfuck,
mother, motherfuck, fuck ♪
♪ Motherfuck, motherfuck,
nice, nice, nice ♪
- Yeah, of course not, dick-face.
- [Woman] Why do you
feel the need to swear?
- [Man] Have you ever lost a deal
because of the language?
- Why do you curse so much?
- The use of vulgarity--
- How do you feel
about Gary swearing so much?
- How the (bleep)
do you get away with saying
(bleep) so many times?
(upbeat rock music)
- Yes.
- At what point in time
is it justifying it and
making it essentially popular
or acceptable, and at what
point does it just become rude
and vulgar?
- I think intent.
I think one of the reasons
I've been able to curse
maybe more than others
is 'cause I think humans
are actually unbelievably
good at having intuition
around intent, and I
think for a lot of people,
they're like, "If I had
to bet my life on it,
"that's just a Jersey
boy being Jersey boy."
I was inspired by Richard
Pryor and Chris Rock
and Eddie Murphy, and their
styles have translated
to my keynote styles.
I feel like I do a little bit
of a stand-up timing process,
and I think that because
I'm not forcing it
and because it's my natural
zone, lil' Jersey Boy action,
people respect authenticity.
I'm not cursing for the sake of cursing.
This is how I'm comfortable
in communicating.
Like when I think about do
I care about my employees,
it feels more like in my
brain, in my heart and my soul,
do I give a fuck about my employees
more than do I care about my employees?
That's how my, that's from my
brain and heart to my mouth.
I am willing to deal
with the ramifications
of me being my full self.
It's not about who cares
what other people think.
It's if you feel good about your intent
and don't think you're
trying to do something wrong,
you have to let the chips
fall where they fall.
And so, for me, that's what it is.
It's I'm not upset or
disappointed or confused
why somebody doesn't like
the bravado or the cursing.
I just have made a choice
that I'm not trying
to do anything wrong,
it's how I communicate,
and you just have to move forward.
As long as it is actually your truth,
you will always over index,
and people have told me
to not curse on stage,
you know, my agents,
who book like, stop cursing on stage.
They were like, "We've got 500,000
"in advance, five speeches,"
when I was making 30,000 a
speech, so this is a big jump.
A 100,000 a speech, but you can't curse.
And it needs to be like the
beginning of you not cursing,
and I was like, "Fuck you!"
(audience laughs)
I don't feel like I need
to swear to make a point.
I would argue that at
times, I use my cursing
as a filter to filter out the people
that are not capable of
seeing the bigger picture
versus being so blocked,
"Oh my god, I heard the word (bleep).
"I can't hear anything else.
"Everything else must be
bad, there's no good advice.
"This is a bad person," that is ludicrous.
It goes into the same
context as the way you dress,
or a million other
variables of ways people
that will judge you because
at the end of the day,
the way you deliver is all
that people really care about
and the way you make them feel.
I'm not cursing to disrespect someone,
and I have empathy and
respect why a lot of people
may not like me or consume me.
There are plenty of people
that don't watch this video
because they saw a keynote where I cursed,
and they were offended.
I am very much in this, I have respect
if you're 62 year old Charlie,
and you grew up a certain way
where the F, where fuck, is disrespectful.
Who am I to judge, I
don't care that it's 2018.
I don't care that it's cool now.
Like whatever, like that's
your world, and I respect that.
And I'll jump in and say, "Hey, brother.
"I see the comment,
like you know, I get it,
"and if you were," I'll
say what I just said.
If you were brought up in a certain way,
I can understand that, but can we agree
that if we get past that,
do you see where I'm goin' with this?
- Yeah.
- Or I'm sorry
I bothered you, or things of that nature.
I would highly recommend--
- You need to do that more.
- You should.
- Yeah.
- Instead of saying
fuck you, I'll show you.
- Yeah.
- You need to say,
I hear you, respect, but
here's why or how or what.
Surely, I would have a bigger audience
if I didn't curse, that
is absolutely true,
and business respect, sure.
I may lose out on a deal
because they were offended,
but in the net-net-net-net score,
I win so many more by
being me and just being me
versus creating a half version of me
for the one conservative
person and leaving the hundreds
of magic business opportunities
that are predicated
on winners making decisions.
You know how I've lost business?
I cursed in a board meeting, and somebody
was very conservative and said,
"Let's not give business
to that fuck face," right?
So.
(audience laughs)
But that's okay because I win net-net,
and I will tell you that it's really,
the one thing I can't do is not be myself.
It's been the thing that
has absolutely separated me
from the pack, and so, I think the truth,
which is a very exciting
answer to this question,
the truth is undefeated.
The amount of people that judge me
and think I'm a bad person 'cause I curse
would be staggering to you.
You just have the capability
of seeing through that
and seeing the truth and the humanity,
like if I spoke with a little less energy,
a little less bravado,
a little less Jersey,
and a lot less cursing, I
would be seven times bigger.
It's not about boring,
just it wouldn't be me.
- Right, exciting.
- It just wouldn't,
it's not even exciting,
you can better than like,
I watch a lot of stand-up comedy.
Like there's great people who don't,
it's just not my truth.
- Right.
- You know, to be frank,
I'm not pumped I'm vulgar.
I take no pride in cursing,
I don't think it's cool.
I really don't, I really don't.
I think it's me, and I don't
know how to be anything but me.
You want a real life lesson?
Figure that out, shit gets good.
(audience cheers)
- This is so (bleep) good!
(audience laughs)
- Jerry!
- Oh, I'm sorry.
(audience laughs)
- That's nice.